ما تخافيش يا عم ما تخافيش لا تخافيش يا
عم هيو جاي هيو جاي لا تعلموا ان اباها
وامها واخاها رحلوا جميعا كثر هم اطفال
غزه الذين تقتلهم الحسره والخوف هذا
الصغير هو تميم داوود لم يتحمل قلبه اصوات
القذائف المنهره فتوقف من الهلع ليرحل وهو
لم يتم بعد عامه الخامس
ثالثا درب الك
رام اما ميار عز الدين فقتلها صاروخ
اسرائيلي وهي نائمه على سريرها تحلم
برحلتها المدرسيه في اليوم التالي لا هي
ذهبت الى الرحله ولا هي رات هذه الصور
التي اعدها لها مدرسوها يرحل الاطفال في
غزه باكرا ويتحملون الم فقد ذويهم باكرا
ايضا
ذهبت الى اصحابك في جنان الغوز مع كل ذوي
انفجار يهتز منزل هاني الهندي لم يجد
اطفاله السته ملاذا اكثر امنا من حضن
والديهم ينام الجميع في غرفه واحده فمهما
حدث يريدون ان يلقوا جميعا المصير ذاته
على باب منزلهم يضعون وثائقهم الضروريه
تحسبا لاي قصف والحقيقه ان هذه حاله
عائلات غزه مع كل حرب وعدوان اسرائيلي
اللهم اني مغلوب فانتظر
اخذوها
خمس جولات من التصعيد شنتها اسرائيل على
غزه خلال ال15 عاما الاخيره ابادت اسرائيل
فيها اكثر من الف طفل في قطاع غزه هذا
فضلا عن مئات اخرين فقدوا حياتهم جراء
المرض وسوء الاوضاع المعيشيه تحت الحصار
ومع كل تصعيد وعدوان يضع الاحتلال الاطفال
ضمن قائمه اهدافه الاولى
315 طفلا قتلتهم اسرائيل خلال حرب 2008
2009 اما حرب 2014 فكانت الاكثر دمويه على
اطفال غزه حيث مسحت اسماء 500
طفلا من السجل المدني لاهل القطاع وفي
عدوان 2021 الذي استمر 11 يوما كان اطفال
غزه على راس قائمه بنك الاهداف الاسرائيلي
حيث ارتقى 72 طفلا جراء قصف الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه منازلهم